The Joe Rogan Experience there's a thing
when you watch uh like a guy win a world
title fight yeah there's a thing where
you watch two of the best in world fight
where everyone gets to watch right right
and these guys who are the the wildest
and craziest of of our population you
get to do this thing which is akin to
combat fully it's just it's like
physical combat with no weapons but your
own body yeah use that as a weapon and
then see who knows how to do that better
and you do it in front of the world yeah
I mean that's that is the ancient [ __ ]
of like single combat right where it's
like each culture or if you wanted to
avoid a war we pick our best guy and we
[ __ ] each other up and there is a
feeling of that definitely with
especially when it's like when it's
clashes of cultures right when it is
like khabib and it is [ __ ] you know
con or whatever it's like these guys
from completely different places and it
almost feels like like that's what's
cool about the World Cup obviously it's
not it's not combat bad sports but there
is something sick where you're just like
these countries this is so much so much
and these people like they got
eliminated but Japan and Korea if they
had won they would have played each
other in the [ __ ] world cup and it's
like
I don't know Japan like they have so
they're so mad I mean that's their
oppression you know what I mean like
Japan [ __ ] Korea up right I mean it's
like those ancient rivalries like
England and France fought each other for
thousands of years you know what I mean
it's like there is it's just so there is
something [ __ ] awesome about and
whenever whenever like a third world
country plays America you don't think
they want to [ __ ] America up because
[ __ ] you or you got all the money in the
world we don't give a [ __ ] we know you
put our dictator in power exactly
come on dude my uncle was his father was
the democratically elected uh guys
[ __ ] minister of the press he got he
got assassinated too you gotta go
[ __ ] yeah this is for the CIA
take this goals for the CIA yeah I mean
it's like War proxy it's cool what was
that article would you highlighted
something no it's uh it's a tradition of
it I don't know that it was a like an
official
um a deeper connection was claimed
during both World Wars football as a
training ground for soldiers and
officers the game as a mimic War
requiring cool thinking self-sacrifice
and physical courage so at least in some
ways It's Kind obviously from that it's
like a proxy yeah it's like a thing that
you can do you could do that instead of
war or maybe can help you practice for
sure but that's especially back then
when they really world wars could pop
off at any time at any time maybe you
can't you know that's the thing with
Combat Sports too it's um it's all of it
is it's the same thing it's like it's
it's just a way there's a thing that
people have inside of them they want to
conquer yeah and the men women want to
do it too they want to do it socially
for sure you know and it's um and some
women physically the ones you want to
[ __ ]
yeah conquer me
it's a weird thing that we have in us
and it makes you wonder if people hadn't
figured out Sports and hadn't figured
out games yeah yeah how much would we be
[ __ ] each other up it seems like
that's what people are designed to do
and all these other things that we do
that all the other animals don't do are
probably the thing that has allowed us
to become what we are right it's
probably the things that have allowed us
to figure out civilization we figured
out ways yeah to get along like let's
play with a ball right let's uh I'm
gonna hit this ball instead of your
[ __ ] head right right I'm not gonna
sneak in think about it a weapon a bad
is a [ __ ] club total weapon like
instead of your [ __ ] head which I
wanted let's use coconuts I'm gonna
pretend it's the code I'm pretend you're
a [ __ ] nut to this coconut yeah and
they said back to them there was a now I
think we researched this too but God
damn that marijuana is ruining my memory
and there was also talk that sometimes
they used a human head yeah I don't know
if that was folklore or true and then
there was another thing that I read that
I never could remember if this is
accurate that the winning team would be
sacrificed whoa that's [ __ ] safe go
to the gods that'd be a long-ass game
where people keep missing whoops what is
it Jamie this article about it says for
instance did the game's winners and
losers get sacrificed at the end of the
game the answer to both questions is no
no so it's almost players are likely but
what if they were you know that would be
cool wasn't meant to go through the hoop
dude it wasn't what is the hoop for that
game was really violent oh [ __ ] uh what
is that uh there's like a hoop
it's all about catching the little gold
thing